si certains footballeurs ont décidé de
faire eux aussi des concessions sur
leurs salaires en cette période de
chômage technique
à l'instar des stars de la juventus qui
ont accepté de ne pas percevoir de
salaire pour les mois de mars avril mai
et juin
certains ont eu notre botte secrète pour
continuer à percevoir de l'argent les
réseaux sociaux car depuis quelques
années et l'avènement d'instagram les
personnalités les plus suivies de la
planète peuvent ainsi valoriser
financièrement leur communauté c'est le
cas de cristiano ronaldo et ses 209
millions d'admirateurs qui est la star
la plus suivie sur instagram toutes
catégories confondues lionel messi et
neymar juniors figurent quant à eux dans
le top 10 des revenus qui même à côté de
leurs feuilles de footballeurs ont de
quoi faire tourner la tête selon
plusieurs spécialistes un poste france
hors is et de cristiano ronaldo
coûterait 800 75000 euros à la marque en
2019 le joueur portugais aurait ainsi
empoché la somme de 42,8 millions
d'euros en plus de son salaire de
footballeur une star qui gagne mieux sur
un stack sur les terrains et il est loin
d'être le seul à qui ce petit business
profite l'an dernier lionel messi a
quant à lui gagné 20,9 millions grâce à
ces publications david beckham 10,7
millions et neymar 7,2 millions côté
français qu'il y a même tapé toucherez
cantal 894 1538 euros pour chaque fois
sponsorisés de quoi supporter un peu
mieux le confinement à sebha c'est
magnifique ce business un mathieu
connais toi qui connais ce qu'il faut
comprendre avant de critiquer
systématiquement les influenceurs dont
j'aime beaucoup de gens faire ça en
général ceux qui font ça sont des vieux
cons rien compris il faut comprendre
qu'aujourd'hui c'est la nouvelle pub à
l'époque par exemple quand on faisait la
pub dans l le figaro ce que tu veux un
magazine et glacé on va dire oh c'était
du 1 % c'est-à-dire qu'on considérait
que cantat à magazine tht cinq personnes
l'avaient feuilleter donc tu vends des
500000 personnes mises magazine la 508
personnes qui avaient vu la pub
aujourd'hui les nouvelles pubs c'est ça
on achète plus de magazines une nouvelle
pub sur les influenceurs au carré tente
par et on dire sur les mecs qui
profitent de tout ça c'est de la pub ce
sont des nouveaux médias et et voilà je
trouve que c'est plutôt devient très
bien foutu